[Music]
david is with us in providence
rhode island hi david welcome to the
ramsey show
dave what's up man hey man how can i
help
talk to you about 15 months ago changed
my life
wow um i have a yeah yeah
um i have i have two questions for you
um one you always talk about the fleece
i have no idea well i know what elise is
but i have no idea what a police is
so when you say that what are you
referring to
well that's a country boy's attempt at
humor when you uh
when you fleece a sheep you cut his hair
off
and it's a country saying it's a country
saying that means you got screwed over
and what that means is a lease is a
fleece at least is a bad deal is what
that means
all right so i own and this is part of
that question
um i own a business and i do fleece a
car
for uh my wife uh the company has
plenty of money to pay for that i know
you disagree with it is it still a bad
idea if it's the rule of business
sure sure it's just a it's an
alternative it's an expensive method of
financing is all it is
you're renting you're renting a car
for your wife and you're paying a rental
fee that's the lease
payment and the rental fee at the end of
the lease you can either buy that car or
turn it in
right correct okay so if you were to
take a financial calculator
and sit down with a financial person
that would show you how to do the entry
into the financial calculator and you
entered in the stream of payments the
monthly payments that you're doing
over the length of the lease and you
enter in the final amount you would pay
for it
versus what the sticker value on the car
is
you will find that on average they are
charging you 14.2
interest that's what i mean by it's a
screw job
but it's never it's never disclosed and
the reason it's not disclosed as a
actual interest rate is because you
haven't technically borrowed money
you're just renting the car
but you can back out the financials on
it and determine what they're charging
you
for the money which is essentially
what's happening right
you're borrowing the money essentially
you're paying car payment right
right yeah yeah and so it's on average
about 14
now some are lower some are higher but
that's the average nationally
and that's why smart money magazine dave
ramsey and anybody else who's done the
calculations on this stuff say it's the
most
expensive way to operate a vehicle
so if you uh if you want to buy your
wife a car you should pay cash
working on it okay so let's you know
what i do is figure out a way to get out
of this lease either get it sold or get
it paid off
if you can come up with the cash just
pay it off you want to keep the car
that's okay with me
but i wouldn't sit there and rent their
money for 14
and that's what borrowed money is it's
renting money and in a sense that's what
the car
lease is and since you're getting
screwed we call it a
fleece you're getting fleeced if you
ever hear someone david say that you got
fleeced it means you got messed over
that's what it means